مباشره الى فرنسا وتحديدا الى باريس وهذه
الصور المباشره التي ننقلها لكم الان
للتظاهرات هناك كما تلاحظون اعداد
المتظاهرين بالالاف طبعا هناك غضب عارم من
تصريحات الرئيس الفرنسي ماكرون طبعا حول
قانون اصلاح التقاعد هذه التصريحات ردود
الفعل حولها كانت غاضبه كانت مندده
وحديثه بالنسبه لهذه لهذا القانون كان
طبعا للمره الاولى من دون اندلاع
الاحتجاجات اكد على اصراره على تطبيق
اصلاح نظام التقاعد ويبدو ان من خلال هذه
الصوره نشاهد الرد الفرنسي رد الشارع
الفرنسي على اصرار الرئيس مصر الشارع على
فرض ما يريد فيما يتعلق بقانون اصلاح
التقاعد ماكرون كان شدد على اهميه ان يدخل
هذا النظام نظام التقاعد حيز التنفيذ
نهايه هذا العام معتبرا انه ضروري وذلك
خلال كما ذكرنا المكالمه
المقابله التلفزيونيه
بعد المقابله التلفزيونيه مباشره كان هناك
خروج لبعض المتظاهرين ولكن اليوم هي
تظاهره الكبرى التي كان مخطط لها خلال
الفتره الماضيه كتصعيد طبعا بعد التظاهرات
المختلفه التي خرجت في الشوارع اذا تتواصل
للاحتجاجات في الشوارع النقابات تجهز
لاضرابات عامه وايضا تظاهرات وطبعا هناك
نوع من
اضراب والتظاهرات في مئتي بلديه في فرنسا
احتجاجات واسعه يعتبر الاحتجاج التاسع
والاضخم كما نشاهد من خلال هذه الصور اذا
هناك اطلاق
للغاز المسيل للدموع
لتفرقه المتظاهرين طبعا في المظاهرات
اهلا ميسون هناك بعض الاشتباكات المحدوده
التي تدور الان في نقطه من احدى النقاط
التي تسير فيها التظاهره في العاصمه باريس
الشبكات ما زالت محدوده حتى الان
وجاءت بعد استهداف المتظاهرين لواجهات عدد
من المصارف واحد المطاعم التي تقدم
الوجبات السريعه التظاهرات ما زالت مستمره
الان اعلنت قبل قليل النقابات العمال عن
800 الف متظاهر في العاصمه وحدها كذلك
اعلنت ارقام بعض المدن الاخرى مثل مدينه
مارسيليا وقالت ان 240 الف متظاهر خرجوا
هناك بالاضافه الى 40 الف متظاهر في مدينه
نيس طبعا هذه التظاهره الفارسيه سوف تنتهي
في الساعه السابعه مساء اليوم لكن من
المتوقع ان تكون هناك بعض احداث الشغب
والعنف لان هناك عدد كبير من الطلاب الذين
انضموا الى هذه التظاهره وهم يتوعدون بالا
يتركوا ساحه التظاهر حتى بعد انتهاء هذه
المظاهره سيتوجهون الى ساحه اخرى
ليتظاهروا فيها طبعا هناك اجراءات امنيه
كبيره جدا اليوم اتخذت هناك 12,000 شرطي
منتشرين لمواكبه هذه التظاهرات بالاضافه
الى ان هناك اجراءات امنيه استثنائيه
اتخذت في محيط المواقع السياحيه تم اغلاق
برج ايفل وقصر فيرساي وايضا عدد اخر من
مواقع السياحيه امام السياح اليوم
[موسيقى]